today's guest is visiting from Austin
Texas
he was born in Ohio
over there in Youngstown Youngstown
uh he is the uh the creator of the kill
Tony show it's one of the most unique
live shows I've ever been affiliated
with I mean it is the dang it's the
Cirque du Soleil
of just damn
just [ __ ]
it's amazing
um you can learn all about that you can
learn about him it's his first time here
uh on the podcast and I'm grateful for
his time Comedian Tony Hinchcliffe
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah because you're a real posture mayor
baby I think you've got that straight
back oh you are the shortest distance
between two points I mean you are you
are as the crow flies man you've always
been
strong in stature that's like one hand
behind my back when I'm performing I
like it like Regal yeah where do you
think that comes from do you because you
kind of have that
that regality kind of I'm sitting here
with Tony Hinchcliffe for those of you
guys who uh aren't familiar Tony is a
comedian and a friend of mine and uh
we're gonna get into his life a little
bit uh thanks for coming on man of
course yeah it's cool bro yeah yeah
where does that come from you think
because you do have a very
I don't want to say it's almost a Brit
it's not is it British what is it kind
of I'm not sure what I'm not sure where
exactly it comes from but when it comes
to stand-up comedy I
my friends back when I graduated from
high school were obsessed with Dane Cook
and I and I was I walked in one day and
they're dying of laughter when he's
moving around it was the vicious circle
and he's walking and Swinging his arms
and I remember thinking to myself I want
to do that but I want to do it without
any of that movement I want it to be
just the words I wanna I wanna figure
out a way and then sure enough when I
got to The Comedy Store and actually saw
real stand-ups like the guys that
sometimes it was the guys that didn't
even take the mic out of the mic stand
that blew my mind the most wow dice
would just walk up to it that I'm even I
don't do that like it's like no mic in
the mic stand or I mean weave it in
there and he leaves it in there the
whole time yeah oh wow yeah yeah because
you kind of you are that night you
really are a sniper of humor you know
it's like where can you it's almost like
you have a nail gun yeah and with these
jokes in it I feel like
um where did you see start out at
because I don't even know that man
honestly I started at The Comedy Store
in the original room yeah I went there
to sign up
[ __ ] Shia LaBeouf's dad as crazy as
this world is I made friends with Shia
LaBeouf's dad at a Starbucks in Burbank
and I was procrastinating starting
stand-up comedy at the time and at the
time right then 2007 Shaya had just
signed this crazy Steven Spielberg deal
and
and he left for like five pictures or
something it was pre we didn't even know
it was gonna be Transformers and all
these other things like it was still
just the infancy of Shia LaBeouf so
there was this like buzz around the
coffee shop I was out playing poker with
these Armenian guys and they're like you
know who that guy is over there that is
Shia LaBeouf's dad he's this wizard
looking character like
so I went and made friends with him and
I told him he goes what's your plan I go
I want to be a stand-up comedian I think
I'm going to go up to this haha or this
uh Chuckle Hut whatever it was in North
Hollywood at the time
and he goes you shouldn't do that you
should start at The Comedy Store they
let them see you start and sink or swim
and because it's gonna you're gonna the
pressure is gonna get to you when you
get there anyway when you think you're
ready for there you're not gonna be
ready for there too so you might as well
not be ready for there now and it was
like great advice it really was wow well
I think for maybe for yeah I think for
some people that advice it's like you
want to get good before you go there
right but he was saying just stand like
just in the firing line and it worked
out man I signed up for that thing and I
watched I got like number nine out of
15. and I watched the first date and it
was the first eight people I had ever
seen do stand up and they were doing
three minutes and they're just like
really bombing I'm like I think I got
this and so for the and for people who
don't know I I remember going to that
too I would go and sign up so you would
go was it Monday night Sundays and
Mondays you'd have to be there by six
o'clock and you'd sign and put your name
in like a bowl or something yeah you
signed this one big piece of paper and
then it goes back to the employees who
are literally like all right that looks
like a new name that looks like a new
name that looks like a new name and then
like after that they sort of just put
people that they know and like sort of
earned it like they've been doing good
lately give him number 15. right he's a
little bit of Mafia back there like
making some choices totally so you had
the eight people that went up and you
were like so damn so you always kind of
have had that confidence I mean you have
this crazy confidence where it's like
how did this guy who's probably not the
largest in stature right gets so much
dense confidence in them yep you know
it's like [ __ ] plutonium or something
I feel like isn't that a real thick
metal I think yeah something like that
I'm not sure you know I think it's a
combination of uh having stubborn
Italian parents and being from a weird
tough crazy neighborhood getting into a
lot of fights with bigger kids and
[ __ ] having to scrap and survive back
in the day a and you know so I'm just
happy to be at the dance yeah you know
when I got to The Comedy Store I'm like
I'm happy to be in La I'm already
winning so like no matter how this goes
it's gonna be great plus I'm gonna get
better you know what I mean like this is
not gonna be this bad again yeah yeah
yeah so you get up
and your ninth in the line yeah and it
went well and I prepared for months and
I blanked out I forgot everything as
soon as I got up there but I literally
said you know as hacky and as cheesy as
it is looking back at it but I literally
go
well
[Applause]
um
I've never done this before I prepared
for months every day I wrote and I
cannot for the life of me remember one
single thing that I wanted to say right
now
and those first state people were all
doing jokey jokes that like you know the
comedians are in the back like Ugh you
know but when I said that there was this
pop in the room people like looked up
because it's like wait this guy's like
being honest right now and it's the
first time they had seen that you know
30 minutes into that show that night
and that's all it was three minutes of
me basically going I'm now yep yep still
can't remember
can't believe it wasn't expecting this
to happen like just non-stop and I'm
still trying to think of one thing and
like what's funny is that one went
really well and then the ones after that
for like months were the bad ones really
when I remembered my jokes was the bad
ones which is pretty foreshadowing you
know for people that know my comedy
style because I like going off script
and you know what I mean like I like
playing and being in the moment trusting
that you know it's sort of like jumping
out of a plane without a parachute like
I like shut I like I like that dangerous
part you know where it's like maybe I'll
say something that I thought of on the
drive to the club that night that's not
finished and it's just a premise and you
have like a race to finish
the joke you know yeah you're like maybe
I'll think about it got a couple seconds
left almost to the end of the sentence
yeah it's almost like dynamite like you
like to light it before you even know
what the ingredients in it are I like to
flip it around in my hands a couple
times before throwing it Ketchup behind
my back once and then see what happens
so that was what 15 years ago
almost 16 yeah May 2007. yeah fun how
about you you started in I started at a
comedy I did a comedy class actually
called Judy Gold comedy class okay and
um Ben gleib was in it wow this man that
called himself chicken man was in it and
he would just yeah he would literally
get up there and just yell Chicken Man
chicken man whoa what happened to him I
know I honestly I think he got involved
in a fast food business somehow
and then yeah it's perfect uh because I
remember him I saw him years later on
the street he was talking about fries
something about fry cooking or something
like a new oil I guess that's helping
those people you know do better or
whatever but um
yeah I remember that and so at the end
of that class you got to get up for
three minutes and I was like oh wow and
you got to form at The Improv and you
got a tape of it so it was like man I
gotta so when you leave there with a
tape and you were on stage you feel
totally like you're a comedian you know
um but I didn't really get going until
I think I probably went over to The
Comedy Store and signed up and Tommy was
over there and uh yeah and it was just
that's really for me I think when you
really start to feel like okay
I'm dropped in on this you know there is
something about The Comedy Store yeah or
there certainly used to be man it's a
cool building yeah it's intimidating all
those signatures so like immediately
people are like whose names are on this
wall how do I get my name on the wall it
looks cool oh there's Jim Carrey in the
same font as this newer that's a younger
guy I just saw him he just walked by
yeah it's like how do I get my name in
that right it's like tricky it's like
screaming from blocks away to like look
at it and take it in it's powerful plus
it's black and white and red yeah it has
a very dark
um
you can feel a little bit of the history
in there it feels kind of sorted uh uh
you know you can feel people's energy
and then they walk through the hall like
what's going on with them even if they
don't say anything you can feel the
nervousness of some people you keep
running into people you're not even sure
if you know them or met them before
um but yeah when you get up on the stage
it's just like you have to do it uh
so fast forward though now you live in
Austin now so you made that move to
Austin yeah and uh it's interesting we
were talking about the first time on
stage because one of the things that
like I know you've done kill Tony for a
long time how many shows have you guys
done now over I think over 600 we're
about to have our 10-year anniversary in
June
and for people that don't know kill Tony
is
well you tell them what it is you tell
them you know well it's like uh it's
like a crazy comedy show where comedians
watch newer or older comedians do one
minute and they sign up for the chance
to get one minute uninterrupted in front
of a bunch of fans on the internet and
then I interview them afterwards and my
guest comedians dose in jokes and you
know contribute we find out more about
the person so not only if I pull their
name out of a bunch of people sign up
names go in a bucket I pull their name
out they get a minute and then I
interview them afterwards so not only do
they win like a minute of uninterrupted
stand-up but then all of a sudden they
they're on a podcast for like eight more
minutes yeah where I interview them and
grow them about their life and make
jokes about their set and their life and
ask some questions and try to figure out
what's different about them I'm sort of
like pulling from like you know I was
raised on like Howard Stern Old School
interviews like he would always ask the
right questions at the right time and
like he'd get more information then it
seemed like he should have out of these
people
and that's sort of what I'm trying to
squeeze out so sometimes I'll just hit
them with what's the weirdest thing in
your refrigerator or what's your biggest
fear or what's your family or you raised
by a single mom and like I've asked so
many of these questions that I've built
sort of a palette kind of yeah to where
I know where things are going and I can
already tell the paintball yeah yeah
exactly it blew my mind I'd done it
before and then so then recently I
really fell in love with it I just you
know I don't know if I forgot whatever
but I so I was down there in Austin and
you guys had me on kill Tony and this is
probably maybe two months ago and I come
out on stage and I had been on stage in
a while so I come out there I'm sitting
there and the and you guys and there's
just it is packed man it's packed and
there's people like there's like people
behind barricades like it is it's insane
the people that have driven Hours come
in they put their name in and they want
a chance to get on stage and then they
get up there for one minute dude one
minute is not enough time
that's the thing one minute is not
enough time to do really almost anything
sometimes and sometimes it's way too
long for some of these people
sometimes it's forever dude I was sat
there I just I was amazed at how much
man my feeling it took me back to when I
first started and there were moments
where you like I remember feeling one
time like my face was trying to get
behind my skull
so that I didn't have to be there with
the uh like I mean I literally was like
how where is this what is going
um but you're right there and people are
it is like the most intense moment of so
many people's lives and you and my I was
sitting next to you and then there's
Brian Redman your co-host and the band
is behind us and you're right I mean you
can feel the fear and the uncertainty of
a lot of these people you can see the
beads of sweat that form on their
forehead right after the set or in the
middle of the set sometimes if things
aren't going well and if the set goes
good you see the beads form during the
interview part you can sort of tell what
they do and don't want to talk about you
know what do you do for a day job oh
they don't mind that what were your
parents like all of a sudden it's like
you can tell because you see the sweat
so that means that the parents are fan
like will watch this they think they're
going to see this so they're not that
not close but they're close enough you
know what I mean yeah I didn't think
about that just from body language and
things I can see how they're feeling and
what to push more on and yeah what I can
get more of and if I make fun of them
how they laugh to that if it seems
genuine that means I can go even harder
because I don't want to hurt anybody's
feelings you know what I mean I don't
know do you
sometimes you are there is no you are a
paper you are a [ __ ] paper cut
sometimes it's so I I it's like how does
that
how do you how does it you were a
[ __ ] paper cut yeah I mean
you know I just did I just don't want to
be the guy that ends up you know being
last I was a skinny little you know tiny
little ratty white trash Italian kid you
know one of the only white kids and a
predominantly black neighborhood that I
grew up in and so like you know say less
people are out there walking around
hitting people with dog leashes and just
a whole bunch of trashy [ __ ] going on
all the time so like I always used words
as a defense mechanism immediately and
then the kids laugh at the one kid that
just got a joke made about him and all
of a sudden they don't want to mess with
me anymore
and you know all the teachers said you
know making fun of people is never going
to get you anywhere and I hated my
teachers growing up I looked at them
like the ultimate bullies you know they
were they were I went to a weird evil
sort of private school bunch of angry
nuns and sisters or whatever damn really
black women
um no oh religious women
yeah
yeah
like damn that's because yeah if you're
going nuns and black women right it's a
[ __ ] law it's gonna be a long
afternoon maybe damn
um but I always wanted to kind of prove
them wrong I'm like I think I can I
think I can do things with these words I
think you can get good at anything and
you know so writing on the roast was a
real pleasure at the time when those
were big televised event yeah you know
so that was like an honor because I'm
like it's a legit job all of a sudden I
have health insurance from literally
making fun of people and then all of a
sudden Martha Stewart saying something
that I wrote into a teleprompter for her
Peyton Manning or whoever all these
Heroes that you know
people look up to all of a sudden are
saying dirty words that I got them to
say because you got the job writing for
Comedy Central right yeah and that's
when the roasts were so fire too Fire
Man fire and then I don't know what
happened but they booked Alec Baldwin
for the last one they booked him too
fast man we should do that one now let's
run it back right post shooting oh yeah
that'd be so good huh is he going on
trial what's the latest with that I'm
not sure that's a tricky one man that's
a tricky one see I moved to Texas so now
I have a gun and everybody has a gun and
like I'm like everybody should have a
gun and then I think about him and I'm
like maybe everybody should have a gun
dude he's shooting out of his weiner too
didn't even have like his sixth or
seventh kid he's had another child too
you can't stop
um giving giving life and taking away
it's like a [ __ ] Game of Thrones king
that's crazy bro
um yeah but I it just blew my mind about
you about to kill Tony show if people
haven't seen it you have to see this
show yeah and one of the Wilder Parts
was one guy comes up he did a minute it
was it was not good right and he's up
there he's like man I was drinking
before I was just so nervous so some of
these people are wasted getting up there
yep and then he goes you were talking to
him about his life and he goes well I'm
a drummer
so then part of your show is you have a
band there and you got a blind guy in it
yep and uh Madness killing it yeah so he
has his own day in Austin D Madness yeah
oh he's really 14th is D Madness day in
Austin he's like a famous musician oh
all those guys are literally hot that is
high level of a musician as you can get
Studio live they do it all that
keyboardist is on tour right now with
Gary Clark Jr and if you see him and
Gary play Gary like is looking right at
him and they're doing the thing it's not
like some background keyboardist you
know they're like they're in the
trenches oh dude they're doing this [ __ ]
together wow they're like a unit yeah
everybody leaves Gary Clark Jr shows
going God damn that keyboardist and like
you know I'm really good friends with
Gary's another reason why I moved to
Austin and uh he hooked me up with that
guy who hooked me up with the rest of
that band and you know we already had a
band in La Jeremiah and Joel and Chris
and they couldn't you know everything
happened so fast during that pandemic
and everybody's you know opinions and
viewpoints were so different and red
band and I hit the road because we had
to do a live podcast there was no you
know everybody else got to go to their
studio and keep doing their show you
know that's right because this show is
live because it's in front of a live
audience we were dying the hottest death
I mean it was horrible we tried for a
while to have people send in minute long
clips and then we would live stream the
interview and everything's clunky and
everybody's internet sucks and people
are just Frozen on the screen and it was
just a nightmare plus there's no
laughter and I feed off of that like I
always say I'm one of the worst podcast
guests I get into these things and I
like shut down after like 20 30 minutes
you know what I mean but in front of a
live audience I could go I could riff
like if we were on a stage with two
microphones we could go for hours I
would have a blast
so we were dying the slowest death and
red band and I needed a crowd period so
and how long did you do that for how
long did you guys do that Zoom stuff oh
man she's traumatizing time in life I'm
guessing it was like two or three months
wow did it almost kill the show was
there ever thought that maybe the show
would stop no I mean oh I mean the
pandemic made it seem like maybe the
show did there was a second there where
it looked like you know once we were in
month two three four
I think we were all of us were a little
bit like what the hell is going on here
like yeah it got weird because remember
first they put all these people in
ventilators and killed basically killed
all those people yeah like I hate to say
that but it was like remember there was
like we just put 200 000 people in
ventilators and then it was like two
days later it's like oh we shouldn't
have put these people
they had no idea what they were doing
God that's crazy scary as hell that
whole thing is so unbelievable yeah but
um so Austin's like come do it here bars
are open yeah I went I went and did a
stand-up show there and uh
in November of 2020 and I hit up Ron
White beforehand because I knew he lived
in Austin and I'm like hey if you want
to do a guest spot on my show I'm doing
it next Friday whatever
and he's like where are you staying
and I'm like I don't know if I got a
hotel yet he's like you're staying in my
penthouse suite on top of the city I'm
going to show you good time and it
really started like immediately out of
cigars in his house so I said God he is
Scott he's got the ultimate setup and he
has a hot tub it's just a key it's just
only tequila and Bubbles
he's the best and he really he like
rolled out the red carpet and oh my God
he sold me on it immediately wow Rogan
was like a Finishing Touch everybody
thinks like oh Rogan went to Austin and
all of his cronies went with him it's
like no Austin sells itself everybody
that goes there you were there you see
what it is like it's nice and the things
that we're doing the live music and
everything and it's just the food is
unbelievable so it was open yeah yeah
and it was the same reason it's like I
don't believe a lot of the [ __ ] that
they're doing with this pandemic this
they're killing more people by locking
people in like especially in the
recovery Community they shut down all
the AAA rooms unbelievable so I had five
friends that overdosed during the
pandemic unbelievable bro I mean just
dot you know like because people need to
have that connection totally do it at a
park six feet apart do something 100
there was other ways to go about it than
just locking in and well it'll be over
any second now one week to stop the
spray read or whatever they were saying
like get the what the I mean looking
back
and I immediately any of us start to
sound like a conspiracy theorist but wow
looking back on it wow economically
just the insanity of shutting down so
much stuff and looking back at what it
actually was like if you were extremely
unhealthy and probably had less than a
year to live this was gonna get you yeah
that's the realities those people that
were or you know they call them
underlying conditions which basically
means like it's a you know the clock is
ticking dang yes they just definitely
they set the Lord you know they just
kind of they've really set the Lord's
alarm a little early on them oh yeah
yeah I mean they took no snooze button
here now the only people I know getting
it are the boosted triple vacs the
people like those are the only because
in Texas obviously there's a lot of
unvaccinated people you know people that
are like I'll give it some time let's
see what happens here I don't want yeah
my face to go numb or whatever the hell
you know what I mean and then you can
always tell who's got that booster they
come up here everything's good no it's
not gonna go away in a couple months
it's fine it's not a big deal you look
right at me why are you making you know
what I mean like but we have to play
along like oh it's okay
[Laughter]
imagine having one extra day every week
that's right more time to cook or grill
you something or griddle up if you do
griddling get you a healthy meal or work
on that novel or just bend some really
good reality TV whatever you like
now it's possible to have that extra day
every week with click up
the productivity platform that'll save
you one day a week on work guaranteed
click up began with the premise that
productivity was broken there were too
many tools to keep track of too many
things in separate ecosystems there had
to be a more productive way well click
up is the one tool to house all your
tasks projects docs goals spreadsheets
and more it's built for teams from one
to one thousand
whether you're in project management
engineering sales marketing or HR click
up has easy to use solutions that create
a more efficient work environment use
code Theo to get 15 off click UPS
massive unlimited plan for a year
meaning you can start reclaiming your
time for under five dollars a month sign
up today at clickup.com and use code
t-h-e-o hurry this offer ends soon
today's episode is sponsored by true
classic
guys let's talk about t-shirts you know
what I'm talking about t-shirts
finding that perfect fitting t-shirt can
be terrible
I swear it's either too tight or too
small or too wide or too arms sometimes
you get one that's two arms it's like
two what why is this so armsy
luckily true classic wants to make every
man look good and feel good
tighter fit in the chest and sleeves to
make your arms pop and room in the Torso
to get things cozy and keep things cozy
that's right and we have an exclusive
deal for our listeners we want to hook
you up with some true classic for a
limited time only get 25 off with the
code Theo at trueclassic.com
that's right almost all of men's
t-shirts are designed to look good on a
certain body type think skinny models
with six packs
but most of us aren't packing anything
but a few beers
and there's nothing wrong with that I I
ain't it's simple you're wearing the
wrong clothes true classic will help you
figure it out get comfortable get going
and upgrade your wardrobe with true
classic get 25 off at trueclassic.com
with code Theo free shipping included on
purchases over 100 100 risk-free
guarantee with a 30-day return policy
true classic when you look good you feel
good dude I had a uh I was singing the
other day I was looking at my balls I
think my balls have Bell's Palsy is that
possible you have balls palsy yeah
I was just like dude everybody's nuts
have bills bills balls yeah I'm with you
I got one side holding on for life for
some reason bring up some Bell's Palsy
let's get a look at it yeah God I
haven't looked at this in a while
you know who had Bell's Palsy was good
old J.R
oh yeah look at that
yeah let's get some better images man oh
my goodness if you don't mind thanks
brother yeah sorry that's a scary thing
Bill palsy is always real real wild man
um
you know I used to be friends with uh uh
Vince from ShamWow right
and he had it and so in his commercials
he would wear that microphone to cover
that part of his mouth so you didn't
notice it oh wow yeah that's incredible
his story's magnificent man he started
he got hired to sell these Rags one day
on the boardwalk in in uh in Venice he
starts selling he was like oh I'm good
at selling these [ __ ] and so he just
like licensing himself bought some
add time
on a couple different Networks
like sports networks and they weren't P
they weren't selling and then he bought
time on Comedy Central and for some
reason the way that it came across it
was like comedic but also like a product
and it just
went to the moon look at this yeah right
here you got to have some good BP right
here oh man
baby that smirk some of these look bad
and then I see that that's the before
I'm like oh man
is
it's rough I like now this lady some
lady some people look kind of good on
them everybody looks like they're like
piratey
yeah some people got that real hiccup in
their cheek it's almost like they have a
hiccup that just got stuck on one side
of them
yeah that droop that Bell's Palsy oh
look at that lady
that uh Asian lady right there the um
uh limpurian I think in the red
oh yeah
oh boy oh yep she's sending signals baby
damn it's wild isn't it though yeah you
don't think about those nerves being in
your face man yeah that's rough but I
said it dice had it bad remember it was
like a news story no I don't remember
Dice Clay at Bell's palsy and he was
scheduled to come to Austin the next
week and it was the only show that I had
been looking forward to I never go see
stand-up comedy shows and I'm like I
want to see dice at Vulcan in Austin
like this seems rock and roll and he did
not cancel that [ __ ] went up
there half his face just
electrocuted just dead half face and he
[ __ ] used it and he talked about it
he did a Sammy Davis Jr impression I
swear to God this [ __ ] killed so
hard it was such a fun show to see
damn yeah it seemed like a real
adventure for your face kind of I've
never had it but I would like to learn
more about it
um but to go back to your show so this
was an amazing part was so the guy said
I he didn't do well at the comedy
but he said I'm a drummer yeah so you
guys have this part of kiltoni where if
somebody plays an instrument they can
challenge somebody in the band at that
moment for the person's spot in the band
yep
and what's Wild is that it's always been
a weird part of the show that I always
had and now all of a sudden we're in the
live music capital of the world so it's
even you know even the stakes are raised
even higher you know some guy who thinks
he can play guitar from St Louis or some
guy that can play the drums from you
know Dallas you know it's a big deal to
these musicians to be in Austin like
they recognize what's going on plus the
pressure of the internet plus they're in
front of a live audience plus they're
going up against somebody on their own
home field and it's never happened where
the resident drummers gotten beat it
hasn't ever because I was like suddenly
because I love the underdog always right
always and I didn't have any attachment
to the band I don't know any of them
yeah so I'm like holy [ __ ] this dude
didn't get this right but this guy has a
shot right now and if he wins every he's
on every show from then on like so like
you're a full-time band member if you
win which nobody ever does
he just got tanked bro this guy yeah
was that the one like he like dropped
his sticks right away or something like
I don't even we had another one recently
where the guy's like I've been waiting
my whole life for this Tony and he
starts and the first drum that he hits
the stick goes flying back and you see
his soul leave his body he ended up
getting it and catching up a bit he put
He put a little challenge in but and you
know the harder the first guy goes that
just means the resident drummers they
are they get to see which is the
ultimate Advantage they're going
second's a big deal on that one
dude and you love like you just Thrive I
feel like you're like a dream you're
whatever the opposite of a dream catcher
is I feel like I'm a nightmare thrower
yeah or like you just like it's just
this world but it's such a the whole
thing the whole show has this it's that
moment that like I'm gonna try this it's
gonna be captured can I do this there's
all those feelings and it's like two and
a half hours of that every episode man
it just it floored me how much fun I had
how much like kind of nostalgia I had
yeah and how much I realized I don't
think I could do those what they were
doing right no I agree people out there
we have regulars the right and perform a
new minute every single week William
Montgomery David Lucas uh you know Hans
Kim
um Michael Lair all these guys that do
this I am enamored by their courage and
their strength and their work ethic it
is an extreme Challenge you have the
whole internet there like yeah I'm sort
of sick of them now you know William's
been doing it four years writing a new
minute every single week for four years
granted a lot of it he's making fun of
red band's mom and it's insider trading
it's a little bit a little bit Yeah
quite a bit some Aphex Twin references
that get a big pop from the crowd just
because they know that he references
Aphex Twin for some reason sometimes so
it's like there was two guys in the
front row yesterday wearing Aphex Twin
shirts because they knew William was
gonna be with me in Nashville what is it
Aphex Twin I barely even know and I'm a
huge music fan oh it's a band yeah I
think so I think it's like maybe
electronic music or something I'm not
really sure it might be like Acid Bath
man I remember we had this lady by us
who
something was wrong with her you know or
something wasn't right with her
I don't know which one it was but she
would always ask if we were going to see
Acid Bath all the time that's all she
said she had like kind of this musical
autism or whatever affects twin best
known as an irish-born British musician
composer and DJ known for his
idiosyncratic work electric style such
as techno ambient and jungle
dude Ambient sound is so crazy man
people put on like white noise you know
and it's just people like like tucking
their kids into bed at night yeah and
[ __ ] like would it be really wouldn't
it be weird if it were like actual this
noise noises white people make yeah I
always wanted to make that
can I speak with the manager
it's just the most whitest [ __ ] ever
it's just somebody putting on their work
shoes in the morning I'll be there for
you would you be there for me too it's
somebody putting stuff in the recycling
bin it's just like small sounds that
[ __ ] white people do
you point me to the closest Cracker
Barrel please
but yeah man it's fun dude and you know
my the trick the secret sauce I think is
I try to keep it interesting for myself
you know what I mean because I've been
there every episode of kill Tony and the
other part is Vince McMahon like it's
really just pro wrestling because it's
like I look at the I always keep our
guests a Secret Surprise No One Ever
Knows who's gonna be there and it's
always either famous monster comedians
or the future you know what I mean your
Brian Simpsons who like are just
starting to get recognized now or you
know three years ago it was Shane gallis
five years ago was Tim Dillon and I'm
literally going same thing with you same
thing with all these guys because I we
know we're in the middle of the lineup
so we know who's coming yeah you know
what I mean and I would literally say
with no hesitation I would say you know
you're not your guest tonight is the
future you might not know him now but he
one day he will be recognized as one of
the biggest comedians of all time ladies
and gentlemen Tim Dillon you know
literally the crowd would be like oh I
was hoping they don't know yet right you
know what I mean yet they didn't know
yeah I want somebody I'm like damn Chris
Rock or I want them exactly but what's
funny is they really don't they want
people like you and him and Shane and
Ari and the people that are in the
moment with their own defined styles
that are still you know there to prove
themselves not just some guy that's like
hey I think you did good you know
instead like you were killing me dude
you're so good at that you're you want
to talk about Snipes dude you have
little hand grenades in your pockets I
don't know man sometimes you gotta you
gotta put them out there bro
um you're like Tabasco yeah
what about What's the diff what's been
the kind of the difference and a lot of
people a lot of comedians moved to
Austin during the pandemic and obviously
the same you know people moved uh a lot
of people didn't really move to
Tennessee as much I mean first of all
things got really weird during the
pandemic I wanted to also be in a state
where somebody could carry a wet it's
like you didn't know how weird things
were gonna get 100 people were looting
it was on the back of like a lot of the
BLM stuff where people were burning and
looting and so it was like I want to
live in a place where at least if I
don't have a Grenade on me that guy two
tables over yeah has one you know I love
La man I was there I thought I was going
actually I always thought I would retire
to Nashville after like growing old in
La it's always how I picture it even
though I toured Texas more than anywhere
else I would do Dallas three or four
times a year yeah it's crazy and Texas
has a big dirty Renegade raw sense of
humor so you know what I mean that's
right down my wheelhouse and I love LA
and still you know sometimes I go back
to LA for a couple days and I'll do the
main room of The Comedy Store be in the
middle of the lineup for their own shows
I'll leave in a veil and I get whatever
I want basically
but my neighborhood was Fairfax and
third right by the Grove right by Pan
Pacific Park it was oh yeah unbelievable
I would go down Fairfax after doing The
Comedy Store The Improv and you make two
quick little right turns it was like the
bat cave in a very residential
commercial area I would like sneak off
in my little end of a one-way Street it
was per I had the most amazing setup and
then one day
my neighbor's like you might want to be
careful tomorrow there's supposed to be
some big like rally some big protests
BLM you know George Floyd
it should be it should get kind of crazy
because if they're starting it at this
park right around the corner I'm like
cool I'm gonna go to Venice Beach and
hang out with my older brothers who live
out there you know 20 30 minute drive
from there so I go to the beach we're
chilling on the patio and uh my brother
at one point I'll never forget it goes
Tony come in here isn't this your street
and I'm like what my street and the
first thing I notice on the TV is the
CNN logo like I realized that we're
watching the national news not like KTLA
or whatever right not somebody's iPhone
not a video exactly not a sketch or
something like the time is matched up
and I'm looking at a police car on fire
at the bottom of my street and then they
cut to another police car on fire and
it's the top of my street so there's one
at Hayworth and uh third and one at
Hayworth and uh Beverly oh yeah that's a
damn luau bro a lot of pork being
grilled baby you know telling you damn
and it is a sight to see when you're
watching the national news and it's
clicking back and forth to both sides of
I mean literally one block it is my
street like it is it's there's only
probably 40 houses there and one of
them's mine so that spooked you spooked
the hell out of me so I go there I'm
like I literally remember saying I think
I have to go yeah and so I got my car
and tried to make it there because I'm
like at least I'm gonna defend it
because at least I'm gonna grab my
laptop right exactly all the little
stuff the what my dad's dad's watch or
whatever the little things
my grandpa's earrings dude if your
grandpa was clouded or whatever he's
always like like a lot of [ __ ] Gotta
Have papa's butt plug you know what I
mean
anyway and I barely make it there uh
another thing that stuck in my memory is
like I was trying to get back to my
place and there's a riot crew of
American like blacked out Shields guns
everything moving down the street and
I'm like oh I have to take side streets
they're about to block this off so like
I'm hustling scurrying like a rat to get
back to my place and then that's where
it really sets in because the chaos was
there the sun goes down and that's where
you know a lot of people in the news
never covered it like they should have
and but it was it was the end of the
Joker movie it was complete Gotham City
they lit the Trader Joe's behind me on
fire like my the back of my building was
to a Trader Joe's like and it's on fire
and the fire alarms are going off and
Smoke's pouring out of broken windows
and the Paper Source across from that
window those are busted out fire alarms
are going off wow
um fires everywhere graffiti everywhere
on trees on telephone poles on cars on
the street on the ground on the cement
on the sides of buildings like the whole
thing exploded it was so much worse than
people ever know because the next
morning the whole neighborhood who takes
great pride in live in living in that
area [ __ ] went out there with rags
and pressure washers and brooms and I
couldn't believe it it was actually sort
of an emotional trip I went for a drive
down third up La Cienega down Beverly up
Fairfax down Melrose and I could not
believe what I was seeing people all out
there cleaning and fixing it and
I think there's sort of a catch to that
is people never really found out exactly
what happened there like it was chaos
and it wasn't that neighborhood it
wasn't people from around there it was
you know a different thing coming up
from Long Beach or whatever but then you
immediately realize like wow well this
place this can happen here it just
happened right so whatever just happened
can happen here and let me tell you
something two years in Texas I can say
with no hesitation it would never happen
there it's absolutely impossible for
that to happen there I was always maybe
people shouldn't you know what I mean I
didn't know where I didn't really have a
stance on guns I was too busy only
caring about comedy but it didn't really
you know that's another thing about
Texas it's like I'm alive now I'm doing
things I'm golfing and then going to the
range and then doing a spot and then you
know having it yeah yeah exactly I mean
that was one nice thing that I thought
it just like I got I have to be
somewhere where I can where things are
open yeah I can't just totally go along
with this thing that like it just felt
insane to me and and of course that's
just my Natural Instincts other peoples
are different I respect that but totally
so I wanted to be in a place that was
open
um yeah what do you feel like the comedy
scene is different like in Austin
compared to La like oh will it do you
think Austin can actually I don't know
if anything can compete with some of
these bigger markets you know just
because of the volume of people
I hear you I think that um
I think the difference is the industry
isn't in Austin like you know Netflix
headquarters and these a lot of people I
think we've lived through an age of uh
stand-up comedy to where we've watched
the complete Evolution we watched it go
from okay well you gotta have clean
three minutes for The Tonight Show or
you know a decently clean 22 minutes for
a Comedy Central half hour to you know
okay you could be a little bit edgier on
Netflix and do an hour and then it's
like kind of like oh Netflix is sort of
cutting down on edginess like unless
you're really established they're gonna
give you notes and and I think that it's
wild west comedy happening in Austin
which is you know obviously what people
want you know people go to a strip club
you don't want to see you know a girl in
a bikini no you want to see [ __ ] I
want to hear the n-word you're damn
right yeah I see some buttholes yeah I
want to see yeah misplaced ingrown hair
I want to see a girl bringing a you know
a candle to the table but just you know
walking on her hands you know I want to
see somebody hell yeah I want to see
yeah yeah I think well one thing I
noticed in Austin was that they stay you
guys locked the phones up over there you
know yep phones are locked up and that's
to you know our shows are still recorded
we have you know cameras rolling on
everything because one thing that we've
learned is that it's good to have your
own footage so that it can't be taken
out of context right I've always thought
that when someone goes for an interview
on any type of net or anything
they should
also if it's a if it's a ground where
they don't trust maybe that there will
be
portrayed accurately they should have
someone record at the same time for them
that's what we're doing so that way it's
like
there will be no real misconceptions
here 100 because it can happen you know
it can happen to anyone at any point you
know even in that crazy video that
happened with me that made me look like
a horrible horrible human being oh yeah
with the Asian stuff yeah is that Hans
Kim was that no it was a different
different guy but 25 seconds after that
his edited version of the video I had my
own video recording of the entire thing
in which you know 25 seconds after his
ends I end up going come on lady relax
you're looking at me like I'm serious
over here you know joke about that joke
about that I'm into jokes like there was
no like scene it wasn't the chaotic
breakdown that it looks like on the you
know 20 second clip that the person
released it's you know it was a it was a
random casual Thursday Comedy Show I
actually yelled at Bobby Lee when I saw
him a couple months ago in La I go that
was all your fault by the way you let me
call you those words for [ __ ] over a
decade without telling me if there was
something wrong well that's one of the
issues people look at there's always
that bait Asian yeah and they will they
let you say all kinds of things or this
or that or joke around with them yep but
they don't email the crew the buddy and
say hey man this guy's with you know
he's you know he he gets it or whatever
right I mean Bobby yeah Bobby goes oh
yeah I felt really bad when that
happened to you
uh and I go well thanks for showing your
support online I'm glad that you saved
it so that you could tell me face to
face a year later you think Bobby would
have ability to email her especially
since he's doing all that browser
hunting all right everyone
[Laughter]
since he's stalking Brendan on his own
whatever that whole debacle was that's
one of the fun it's almost like a sketch
show you know when you go watch that
it's like they had like screen like
Brenda doesn't own a computer which is
the funniest part of all of it right
yeah like he's like dude he's getting
this research they have like screen
grabs on his phone
uh the whole thing was just so
ridiculous it's wild
um I couldn't get enough of it that was
like my that was my that was my like
thing I switched from like police
interrogation videos to like following
the shop and Bobby Lee thing for a while
it's on my YouTube algorithms just
filled with Bobby Lee Brendan Schaub
kalila like I know weird um because I
can't there's some sometimes I'm on one
thing and then sometimes I'm like maybe
they did do that like it like switches
quickly it's like if you're talking to
you know you're gun toting friend and
then all of a sudden you're with your
liberal well if there were no guns in
this and I mean like sometimes you can
see both sides of the argument I'm like
well I mean Brendan you know you some
you know hate happens to people people
are jealous you know you're a fighter
turned comedian and then all of a sudden
I saw one clip where kalya was like yeah
I'm a lot better at the internet than
people think and I'll destroy someone
it's like from an episode years earlier
and like I'm like whoa this is all wild
because people have made some serious
breakdown videos of that stuff oh it's
well I'm amazed at how like the uh What
uh there's such a world now with
podcasting there's also like this soap
opera undercurrent of all of it you know
I don't play it you would think kill
Tony would be a big poker and like I get
it people like drama but I don't want
I've always looked at it like if you
play that game those are the types of
fans You're Gonna Get You Wanna you
wanna be drama you want to do gossip you
want to do this you're going to end up
then you're not even in the comedy world
anymore all of a sudden you're in the
drama world you know what I mean and I
look at some of the people with
successful YouTube shows and podcasts
that aren't stand-up comedians and I see
them doing that yeah like Ethan Klein
show does that a lot yeah I notice they
get a lot more like but it's big he does
a great show yeah and Ethan's a you know
we've had some great conversations man
he's extremely deep guy
um but yeah I think that's just their
world I guess it's also what is your
world right you know and what do you
like like some people they like that
right it's like I guess I don't know if
I care about it that much you know
um
but it's definitely it's it's crazy how
there's just such a microcosm of like
there's like a couple hundred channels
that put out clips that I'll see that
are of me from different shows and stuff
and I'm like there's a whole little
ecosystem out here going on of channels
and stuff and it's like you want to
fight or whatever you're just like what
are you gonna you know it's like there's
there's just so much podcasting it's
it's really its own
it's its own I mean it's a huge world
now yeah with layers and like there's
like
people making like vid like reviewing
pie like reviewing clips and things that
have happened it's it's gotten pretty
deep man oh yeah there's people
reviewing those people's review shows
and stealing their ideas and doing
rip-offs of their shows and like you
know what I mean like it's like they're
reviewing the review yeah there's like a
sports center for podcasts almost now
where they're like looking at highlights
and replaying things and like it's
interesting though it's definitely
fascinating to be a part of the uh
little Universe
um but what do you see that's different
about that Austin scene what do you
think like with Joe's Club being built
what do you think what do you think it
can get to that place where it is like
the third biggest city for comedy I
think it'll be number one
I really really truly believe that
because I think that
um I mean I already see it I see the
amount of tickets that we sell casually
like like it's nothing like people are
just dying for it and waiting for it and
people are flying into Austin now when
they used to fly into LA and New York to
have a comedy weekend you know if they
wanted to see
you know
three nights of shows that's where they
would go but now words out syringes are
on the street porta potties on the
crosswalks in L.A you know about that
they just started putting porta potties
at the big crosswalks no yeah so like
you want to cross Hollywood and Vine
there's a porta potty there right next
to the button to cross the street and
they they ain't clean spoiler alert it's
not like a brand new it's not like one
of those like
one time dude we stayed in there for a
couple hours damn we're hot on drugs and
it was late we had probably four a.m and
you had you got to get some cover you
got to get a little bit of shelter at
those hours especially in New Orleans
you know it's got that real a lot of
human vampires dude a lot of dudes will
[ __ ] trying to just sink their teeth
they need a dick out there at night you
know I'll run a French Quarter sounds
like my kind of party all right on you
know if you're missing something you
might look into lost and found
but I'll tell you what you won't find in
there your hair
people lose their hair every day
one to hundreds of thousands of people
are losing their hair right now
but
that can change with keeps
keeps offers a simple affordable and
stress-free way to keep your hair
I've ordered keeps I've been using some
of their products
I find that I have a lot more hope
for the hair that I'm currently growing
than I had before
that hope helps keep me a little bit
more relaxed less stress
remember prevention is key treatments
can take up to four to six months to see
results so act fast because two out of
three men will experience some form of
hair loss by the time they are 35.
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss like a good man
go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to receive your
first month of treatment for free
that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o to get your
first month free
keeps.com slash Theo are you wasting
money on subscriptions ask yourself that
and ask honestly
don't BS yourself ask honestly are you
part of you get a Bible of the month or
something
are you getting something beef jerky
they're sending every three weeks they
email you a couple sticks or whatever
are you doing something else something
your wife don't want you doing getting
barrettes are doing something naughty I
don't know
but you might be wasting money on
subscriptions eighty percent of people
have subscriptions they forgot about
eighty percent that's everyone
that's right but there's this great app
I use that helps me track all of my
expenses and because of it I no longer
waste money on subscriptions I don't
even use it's called Rocket money
it's formerly known as true bill
and the app shows all your subscriptions
in one place and cancels what you don't
want for you rocket money can even find
subscriptions you didn't know you were
paying for
you may even find out you've been double
charged
to cancel subscription all you have to
do is press cancel and Rocket money
takes care of the rest that's what they
do for you because they care about you
that's why
that's it cancel unnecessary
subscriptions with rocket money today go
to rocketmoney.com Theo
seriously it could save you hundreds per
year that's
rocketmoney.com
t-h-e-o people say it's the best app
they've ever used stop wasting your
money rocketmoney.com
Theo but listen I think that I here's my
other Theory but is there enough
comedians will there be enough this
that's my question guys like Tim Dillman
have gone there and left yeah
Tim's there he's just waiting for Joe's
Club to be full-time Tim has more
property in Austin than anybody he talks
a lot of [ __ ] but he's like buying it up
really oh yeah dude he gets it Tim's out
here killing it and Segura and Christina
and me and Joe and Ron White and a whole
bunch of the the youth the future Danny
Brown you know Danny Brownie Brown yeah
no doubt I'm very close with Danny he's
my honey oh my God I just ate mushrooms
with him a couple weeks ago oh god oh so
much fun he ate like a baseball gloves
worth of mushrooms like and and I was
tripping my balls off but I didn't need
as much as him and he just
was so fun he's popping out of Corners
being all silly and like funny and stuff
times have changed like a lot of
brothers wouldn't do mushrooms back in
the day you wouldn't see a brother on
psychedelics you know it just wasn't
I don't know I think maybe black people
had too much fear and maybe even inside
of them on their own history but you
don't want to add any you don't want to
you know Season up The Cauldron any you
know but now yeah you got a lot more
um
you know kind of mustache Brothers out
there who will uh do some uh drugs you
know psychedelics oh yeah it's fun it's
cool it's cool to see a brother out
there tripping and you're like hell yeah
dude this is we're getting equal yeah
we're doing it we're all part of the
same universe yeah we're all part of the
same thing but people are coming to
visit those New Yorkers are that are
real joke Gunslingers we just had a tell
on the show on Monday he just did a
whole weekend in Austin and he's looking
at it with a twinkle in his eye like
wait what are you guys doing here this
does you guys do this every Monday and
then you do okay like and to any
comedian
you know Comedy Store style you know or
comedy seller style they come to Austin
and they're looking at it
with like okay so maybe I'll spend like
a week out of every month here you know
we get Ari Shane and Norman there for I
know they love it four days a month and
Rogan's bringing good Comics down to be
on his show yep I mean that's what made
me think about it was like I would like
to go for a month and just have an
experience of it what does it really
feel like to be there go out get you a
sandwich get you a coffee get you a you
know you know find a wife or something
or see it and you know and do comedy at
night while you're trying to do that you
know and and have a you know like a
lifestyle of it I can't believe how much
I love it wow you know spending the
whole 15 First Years of my career in La
I never would have guessed that another
option would work
um I'm amazed at that too living here
yeah exactly you know and like all of a
sudden you're comfortable and you're a
little bit better rested and you have
maybe a new hobby or something something
to you know because I think in La it's
or New York perhaps it's easy to just be
like oh I gotta work I got to work it's
only about the next joke you know what I
mean I gotta I gotta but then you're not
living you're not experiencing things
you're not taking note you're not having
great conversations where you say
something that you realize might be good
on stage like living is a huge part of
what we do right I agree and I think one
of the things that's happened to
Hollywood over the years is it used to
be that people went people had these
like wild like people went there with
their energy and and like made their
dreams happen wrote scripts and but now
it's been so much like the Children of
Children and nepotism and you know third
generation screen right that it's like
the people writing the things and
creating the things they're not they
don't have as much life experience
anymore they're maybe their grandfather
did maybe their mother did but they're
still kind of riding off of those old
stories and energies so they're not as
tuned in to some of the reality right of
of just like um
of creativity really you know another
thing that I think is that it's much
easier for people to be jealous and
competitive there's a lot of billboards
there I noticed that my last trip there
I'm like wow I just always
didn't notice like I mean the Billboards
were just part of like the skyline it
was just a tree it like Blends in with
LA
and as I'm looking up there I'm
realizing oh my God that show looks like
crap that [ __ ] looks like crap that
movie I has it looks it tells its whole
script right there in the billboard like
and I'm judging these Billboards and I
realize like this whole place does that
to people like all of a sudden I'm
daydreaming about why does that idiot
have a show that's not gonna work wow
comedy Central's dead as hell you know
you're looking at the build itself yeah
and I'm looking at these Billboards and
I realize I'm thinking about this they
have me thinking about these things
which in Austin you can't there is no
like oh oh I wish I had that or this
person would be better for that or this
is where that should be like right so it
takes a lot of that business and the
jealousy and the like oh look at the it
takes a lot of that Glitz out of it and
stuff like that and also it's like these
people you know in LA and New York It's
the Last Stand because we've learned now
that the podcast is the way you can have
your own show and build your own fans
with people that are into what you're
into and like the sound of your voice
and want to hear it so that old model of
like all right let's throw this to the
people and see who likes it like it's an
old school model and it takes away from
the ability to build something and now
people are like oh if I didn't start a
podcast now I can't start now I'm In Too
Deep now but it's like who knows it's
like Bitcoin or nfts or whatever like
who knows what the anything is yeah
well there are some things that are
great about La too though it's like the
weather is absolutely unbeatable you
can't beat it and there's no there's not
even any question about it I don't know
if there's anywhere in the world you can
beat the weather there yeah there's
barely any bugs there's no allergies in
the air no poisonous animals Jesus man
yeah a third of my childhood was filled
with [ __ ] poisonous animals dangerous
animals Street animals [ __ ] nighttime
animals [ __ ]
just [ __ ] mean owls everything man it
was all [ __ ] just harrowing dude I
remember one time my brother and I are
asleep in our bedroom right a [ __ ]
owl like a nighttime owl or whatever
shattered right through the [ __ ]
window in our bedroom dude oh my god
dude scared me so bad bro we had no idea
what it was we didn't know if it was
like a burglar or what you know that
means someone in your family is gonna
die soon if an owl flies through your
window oh yeah everybody died
um so yeah I wish I'd known that at the
time though
um but there are things that are great
about it the access to people that are
there is also nice like you know I have
friends like my friend James Blake lives
there he's a musician and he's like I
would have never got to meet him if I
didn't live in LA and it is kind of
name-dropping but he's also like one of
the most unique people that I get to
talk to like all of us and it would have
never met each other if we had if it
hadn't been for La oh yeah I'm grateful
for it just like I'm grateful for
Youngstown I think that you know being
from a place and living and having the
experiences of being in you know a
diabolical Place gets you to appreciate
everything that happens after that right
like you wouldn't be quite as P at peace
here in Nashville if you didn't know
that it takes an hour and a half
sometimes to drive from one gig to
another in LA or from the airport to
your house in L.A those little things
like here you get out at the airport
you're here in 10 15 minutes right yeah
same thing with me in fact I try to set
new records each time the airport's like
a place that now I have like great pride
and trying to get home in like seven
minutes or eight minutes it's crazy
um yeah I guess there's yeah there's
definitely a lot of things and it's also
like this is part of the journey it's
like
um you know uh communication like is
more free on podcasts and so it would
make sense that maybe they expand out to
different areas over time it's been
really interesting to be in a different
place and have access to different
guests and like unique people that
um normally may not have be able to get
on a certain platforms or weren't even
able to get on like kind of podcasts and
stuff so that's been uh really
interesting and kind of seeing like
what's who's the next person that I'm
going to get to meet that would be like
really really awesome to have come on
from here like we got Mike Rowe is going
to come on right so I'm really excited
about that like I don't know if I would
be able to have him on if I weren't in
this area so
um yeah there's different things about
it and I can go back to LA whenever it's
always there it's still like you go back
The Comedy Store The Improv places that
I love the Laugh Factory has become
um it's it's still great uh it's gotten
better actually just busier over there
so the stages are still there
um and it's fun and yeah man when I go
back to the store it is a party those
are my people you know those people that
have worked there forever
um you know we're so close and we have
so much fun and it's like a reunion it's
like a different vibe instead of being
there all the time it's like you know
it's like going home and visiting you're
in a family yeah in a HomeTown
yeah
yeah it's interesting that is it's like
and we also have to be supportive of the
places we are it's like you you have to
do that like you have to kind of
champion where you are to an extent in
order to be able to survive there right
and um and have like a nice perspective
every day
um let's talk what's some news that's
going on what do we got Daddio
here we got Tesla reveals new AI robot
Optimus do you see this no
this is wild it will cost under 20 000.
oh my goodness what can it do
that's what I'm wondering look at it
ah
I mean okay can walk yeah kind of dude I
don't even know I feel like this thing
couldn't even work at uh I don't think
this thing would make the band at Chuck
E cheese honestly yeah it's quite the
awkward strut like if that was a human
that walked like that you would not
trust it oh is that waving oh get out oh
it looks like Biden oh yeah it does
you're [ __ ] waving at nothing
um
dude for me this the thing about Tesla
is I put in them to get that truck
[Music]
two years ago yep and it's like I keep
extending my current leads because I'm
waiting for that truck and I I don't
know I don't care about this [ __ ] can I
tell you something have you have you
touched one yet have you like been in
one uh-uh I I have is it worth it the
coolest thing I've ever seen and I'm not
a big Tesla guy at all I like I like gas
powered you know American-made oh yeah
sports car oh I want to burn to death if
I get in a wreck yeah exactly and but
this one and I saw pictures of it just
pictures and video online before and I'm
like that doesn't even look that cool
seem that cool in person man that thing
is the most undeniable baddest it goes
from you know a low rider to all the way
to a monster truck like you can raise it
and the Technology's absolutely insane
you know Elon Musk is in Austin Texas
yes another buddy old pal
and you were able to get in there yeah
yeah you got in the Tesla truck oh yeah
and where'd you sit in the front or back
the front wow yeah and it's all
beautiful in per it's the most different
I've never seen anything where a picture
a video online is so much different than
seeing the actual thing I've never seen
a bigger like
uh
just difference in how unbelievable it
is in person did it feel like it's kind
of like a comedian that's really really
great live but doesn't translate to TV
or Clips you know what I mean there's a
few of those that's how it is it's like
powerful live
it seems like nothing else it seems like
a spaceship it almost like a DeLorean
but
new brand new but does it feel like kind
of like a [ __ ] truck or does it feel
kind of [ __ ] tough or does it feel
tough this is [ __ ] like it does it feels
Army tough really like a Hummer meets a
you know like a ram
but electric it doesn't even seem
electric by its appearance
oh if that makes sense yeah that's
amazing amazing stuff I want that yeah
that and that's the one you got in right
like that yep wow and it is so cool and
so fast and so crazy
yes you just want to touch it I'm so
ready for that yeah God I want to make
love in the back of that a lot of space
unbelievable
oh wow Antonio Brown
exposed himself to stunned guests in
Hotel pool
oh he showed his butt to that whoa oh
that son
was he naked in this pool
this might be another country
you know his Hog's probably so big that
he's having sex with that girl the whole
time
[Music]
dude if you had a crazy long wiener you
would have to
you gotta show it to somebody no doubt
do fun things with it measure for first
downs on the football field all of it
you know what I mean there's a lot of
fun things I mean my buddy uh get like a
one foot marker on it like tattooed
yeah definitely get like some somebody's
trying to like measure something you hit
him with that next thing you know y'all
are making love you know God it's just
like through the sleeve and pull this
arm like behind you and just sort of
like wave to people with your penis
I'm just thinking here it's some good
it's fun to draw I just feel like I
would if I had that if you had because
it's almost like having like a
like if you have one of those little
dogs you get to carry in a thing and
show it and take it on the plane you
know yeah it'd be crazy if you had like
a small bag and you snuck you know like
you poked it out the top yeah or if you
put took one of those little service
animal vests and put it across it it's
just like here yeah don't pat it it
doesn't like to be padded
you can look at it damn you got that
service wiener dog that's crazy yeah
what's the longest wiener they've ever
had can you look at well here he is
right here look at this he's flashing
his wiener out the water oh yeah there
it is and they're looking and you know
those men are even looking you could
tell with that blur it is absolutely
humongous bro I mean look at that thing
look at that that thing I mean that
that's like an alien sighting or
something that looks like a UFO
wow look how long that is
dude that looks yeah
that looks like it's got some hit points
if this is a result of breath of the
Wild
[Laughter]
bad thing wow that's crazy man see it's
just it's interesting if you had a it's
like if you had a great week you should
be able to show it to somebody every now
and then if you got a regular wiener
sure right that's disgusting no one
wants to see a regular wiener oh but a
giant wiener is something that both boys
and girls can agree on yeah like it's a
it's it's worth showing off what's the
biggest wiener buddy can you look at
that we might have a Blocker on here
this is interesting biggest wiener ever
this is good this is podcasting gold if
you ask me is it yeah hell yeah biggest
wiener me and you finding out together
exactly the record for biggest penis in
history
oh yeah that is kind of exciting yeah
eight feet nah
oh it's a blue whale that makes sense oh
he's got that okay uh yeah we're gonna
have to put human in the mix here
man you just gave away your cookies on
that one
18.9 no way wow Roberto Cabrera wow no
way Latino coming in oh man that just
might be his like brother he might have
a Siamese twin just connected to his
groin area dude this guy he could break
a yard with that thing dude he's halfway
to work has smashed the previous record
with his Mammoth penis measuring an
incredible 18.9 inches let's see more
verbage on it
uh what the man with the world's largest
penis has revealed his daily life is
like
uh as he rejected the possibility of
having a reduction 54 year old Roberto
esquibal Cabrera
wow from Saltillo Mako
has a penis measuring a record-break in
18.9 inches wow damn
that's unbelievable man God
I can't believe him I would hate that
though
would you though
yeah cause then you have to wash your
penis that's true that's a that's a
whole that's a whole other five minutes
put lotion on your wiener um
if you had that much wean or what he
probably has people to lotion that
weiner you think yeah he probably is
but then again what's the biggest vagina
is the real question here what's the
deepest human vagina that's a great
question what is the deepest human
vagina bub
B this is see now we're really getting
into something here yeah people never
look at this huh right
because that's the real because you
can't put it all the way you can't
obviously Anna swan
okay here we are biggest vagina in the
world
I just pop up it's just a picture of me
penis in the world okay scroll
have yours uh keep scrolling that's
nothing wait did you see that was the
guy yeah scroll back up no up up up
that dude that's him Robert Esquivel
Cabrera wow look at that guy world's
largest Venus the world's biggest vagina
belong to Anna swan oh my goodness wow
she died in 1888.
19 inch circumference it's a little less
than a little less than the
circumference of a rugby ball
she was a Scottish giantess and reached
a height of seven foot eight inches
she also reportedly delivered the
biggest newborn ever recorded 23 pounds
12 ounces wow it's tough
time oh that's a [ __ ] bantamweight
dude that is unreal
oh there's the guy oh there's Roberto oh
my goodness zoom in a little here Bucky
look at the girth of that thing dude he
has it taped like one of those horses
legs when they put the tape on it before
it run like it's about to have its own
boxing match oh my God bro yep you've
got to be kidding me he has a beer
koozie on it
oh my goodness
look at this wow
wow this is incredible
oh my goodness Jesus great hair too huh
oh my God look at it do you see it in
his pant leg oh my God large in that
video up but don't turn the audio on my
God he literally he walks like he has to
walk like that Tesla robot too
hahaha
I'm like nobody walks like that robot
and then all of a sudden world's largest
penis maybe the robot has a big penis
dang man see that's what I wouldn't want
to do it's almost like you're like I
feel like you're at church every time
like it's like noon at church and it's
like [ __ ] it's ringing against your
knees
and or you get hard at a place where
you're like where you don't where you
shouldn't like that oh
but even if it gets hard it's just like
hitting again there's no like it's got
to just be painful because all of a
sudden it's just trapped it's like Harry
Houdini and all your blood like you must
lose like a third of the blood on your
body yeah when it gets hard he just like
goes stupid just like
all the blood leaves his body there's a
cost man there's a cost to everything no
doubt what other news we got here
so this is one thing that's been popping
off a lot is this kind of drug-induced
homosexuality right here
you can turn the audio on it so this is
a new drug no it's just like a lot of
men are
there's like been a pattern of men
becoming gay based on drug use look at
this
oh my God you see there's a straight man
one more time you can tell they don't
want to be here but the drugs got them
here look at that
damn boy
how do you know they're straight you
could tell look at them
look at that
one of them called the other one I think
of yeah and
yeah he's like you're gay dude drugs God
I'm like maybe I do like dudes see that
one person comment see that bam boy what
what happened boy nothing gay
who gay bro you see that's crazy bro
that's interesting I remember a guy
tried to get me to do cocaine with him
once and then be gay you know try to
lock me in a bathroom when I was trying
to go to the airport
how did what was his move he like went
in for a kiss or something yeah he said
the doors are locked and I just believed
him you know so obviously it would be
like the worst
I'd be so easy to kidnap or whatever you
know I didn't I just believed him and
then because he also had the drugs right
so it's like I'm Milling around and it's
like how close to gay do you want to get
for this drug right
yeah and he just yeah something he told
me he like I remember took his watch off
and put his watch on me just [ __ ] that
like they trap you in like that oh yeah
that'll do it and you know like what
time is it and they pull you know like
right pull you close or whatever yeah I
don't know bro but next thing you know
your handcuffed oh yeah and you're
you're just a gay you know it's just
drug induced gay but what else we have
any other news that's going on I don't
care about this oh I like this let's go
to that two female cops arrest a shop if
your random guy comes in and does it for
them
didn't do anything why are we just
reading for it please stop resisting I
didn't do anything
let's go
okay
okay Thief
wow
this is the type of stuff you're going
to be seeing more of I think is that
vigilante style stuff you know like I
was at a store not too long ago a CVS
and somebody in there was stealing stuff
and so then you have then you just get
the biggest guy that's in there it's
just like some chubby kind of vest he's
red vested so now they have to con
they're confronting people it's like
people it's not even their job
description you know
yeah man I mean that's another thing was
at towards the end of my La tenure like
the the the windows were boarded up at
all the drug stores near me where I knew
the people that worked there and it's
like you know my neighborhood friends
and there's plywood over the windows
because you were just allowed to steal I
guess up to a thousand dollars worth of
stuff which it's almost impossible to
steal over a thousand dollars worth of
stuff
you know in one trip at least in one
trip yeah yeah so yeah I'm not gonna
Supermarket Sweep Shop remember that
yeah that's basically it it really is
L.A yeah never ending Supermarket Sweep
yeah it's just but it's like it puts
people in on edge you know it makes it
you know I noticed when I go back that
CVS I like feel like okay what could go
off in here you know it makes me have
like a different kind of
um relationship with the other people in
the store what's going on where do I
kind of position myself a little bit
like it makes you kind of pay attention
a little bit more like I do notice
myself kind of having a little bit more
insight on my surroundings which is good
but also it makes me kind of more
fearful of just people which I feel like
is kind of bad you know it's like you're
just waiting for the next person to be
that scare bear you know right yeah
people are out there being wild not
everybody's not everybody's thriving in
these times so like I mean you have to
ask yourself what would we be doing you
know what I mean if we had nothing and
needed something same thing yep exactly
we'd be in there getting talked to by
the big guy in the red shirt
and it's when people start when the
fabric of kind of like that we are all
buying into the idea that
this is a country and these are the
rules when that starts to kind of like
you know fluctuate I feel like and you
see sir it's just so many years of some
people getting certain treatments some
people get another treatment you know
when you start to see that like there's
just so much of like
um your politicians just you know glad
handing with their buddies and giving
these contracts you start to feel like
there's not really that American Dream
there's not really that thing that can
uh that everybody's not playing fairly I
think it starts to make people not
respect the game anymore you know but
you still have to sit there with the
Monopoly board but you know that they
don't respect the game and that's when
you [ __ ] turn the shoe in and you get
that little Cannon and you just start
[ __ ] just hauling ass bro just
hanging out on Baltic [ __ ] blowing
grounds I could tell it's been years
since you played Monopoly I think
and but it's like you just baltics the
Hood by the way you know that's a rough
neighborhood Celtic was gangster dude I
would just get Baltic and to stare over
there and [ __ ] Flex
just call people names and they pass
through dude yell [ __ ] yeah baltics over
there with Mediterranean it's a lower
income area is it what was over there
Baltic
yeah maybe it was I think so
what else we got in the news man
wonder if there's anything else we want
to cover here
I know you get a couple shows tonight
man I'm gonna come and do one we're
gonna have fun thank you bro that was so
much fun last night there's nothing I
love more because again I'm an old
school I was raised on like pro
wrestling I didn't have a dad in my life
growing up
so like there's some one of the big
parts of pro wrestling that makes it
wildly successful is the element of
surprise which I love more than anything
combining that in our weird world of
stand-up comedy so there's nothing and
again I do it every week on kill Tony I
literally never announce who the guest
for that live show is gonna be
so
you know getting to have will everybody
thinks William who they already know
from my show is bringing me up and
instead he's bringing up Nashville's own
Theo Von you know and last weekend in
Columbus I got to bring up
Chappelle everybody thought I was gonna
bring up Rogan and instead I'm bringing
up Ohio's own
Dave Chappelle and the groom I mean the
pop that element of the people looking
at the person that they came with like
no [ __ ] way and then you see the
outline of Chappelle the iconic and the
same thing with you they see that
[ __ ] mullet fluttering in the air
like we made it that white base show
here we go that's that lady bait dude
yeah you know there is that's so
interesting I never thought about like
that it's like when somebody's like
surprises and ran into the Ring The
Ultimate Warrior coming out at number
29th yep anybody else who ran out it was
like oh it's good but it ain't the
Ultimate Warrior the other one the other
one the Undertaker the lights go out and
you hear the bell toll yeah and you just
get the chills because you're like no
way right and then and that's you know
that's that's a big one he lives in
Austin as well the Undertaker Elon Musk
something happening over there there's
something cooking they got to get him on
stage man that's the thing we just those
people have to get on stage and do some
time I look I think it's fascinating I
like the idea of an underdog place I
like the idea of something new yeah
obviously I'm really curious to see
Joe's Club it looked great when I walked
through it I was like wow this is really
going to be cool oh yeah and the
adjustments and the the way that it's
being built is by real comedians you
know every other Comedy Club even if it
was owned by a guy that used to be a
comedian or host the shows you know all
those weird little places scattered
around the country it was never done by
actual successful real touring comedians
that could do theaters or Arenas or
whatever yeah to really surgically make
it I mean and
you know they we had a Louie in town
three weeks ago or so and he came in and
even made one more final adjustment you
know what I mean he's like yeah it's
perfect if the ceiling was just 12
inches lower I think it'd be would be
even better than perfect and we were
like and you know it's just you're
watching the magic happen Joe looks at
the construction I think we can do it
you know yeah we could do it yeah we'll
just add a few few days
all right wow so those little tiny
screws on like this Boeing 737 are being
tightened to yeah and the entrances and
like the class of it is gonna be crazy
like it's Gonna Be Heaven it's gonna be
what we loved about The Comedy Store but
also with a little bit of a rock and
roll and also a little bit of like a The
Shining Vibe you know that hotel from
The Shining it's gonna be like sort of
really classy and cool like that but
also dark and creepy too so magic we're
really excited yeah yeah I could feel
just excitement even when he was walking
me through it you could feel like you
know it's interesting to see somebody
like that get excited you know who's had
so many unique things happen to them in
their life yeah it's cool to see
somebody get excited do you think that
Joe would ever start a platform
because obviously having a club is is
amazing right it's a it's a tangible
thing where you're right there you can
get up on stage you know it's like this
is the real art yeah but I wonder if he
ever creates like a you know like his
like his own YouTuber like his own
because I feel like he would be the one
obviously you know he has the most
gravitational pull he could and the
thing is I think he already has I think
that he just doesn't want need or want
all the credit you know what I mean it
doesn't need to be called the Rogan
Network he just pushes the things that
he believes in you know what I mean I
think we're all part of that extension I
mean there is no question that he is
that his show is the new Carson it's the
new Tonight Show like getting on it and
being part of that Universe it means
you're going to get bigger
even when they came after him even when
they tried to cancel him he got bigger
everything just gets bigger even I when
all the crazy stuff happened to me and
there's a few days where I'm like oh my
God am I about to go be a crab fisherman
in Alaska like what the [ __ ] am I about
to do and to see that oh my God
everything got a thousand times better
like it's you know
so I think he sort of already has this
universe you know and you know if they
ever really really really come down on
free speech and you know if YouTube gets
crazy or anything like that then you
know there's totally something that's
gonna have to happen
um but I think right now he's he's doing
everything he can for like other people
it's incredible how he you know one
thing that's not often talked about is
you know sometimes you'll go see some of
the biggest comedians on planet Earth
and you'll notice that their opening
acts like aren't always really like
they're not like their own Killers like
you know what I mean like a lot going
back to last night like I'm like I
I wasn't like uh I hope I can't follow
Theo you know what I mean because we
we've always done The Stance we've been
growing up before and after one another
for over a decade continuously I and
this comes you know and this is
something that Joe and I have always had
in common is like we Thrive we love the
idea of giving the people the best
possible human crazy ass show and
pulling it off you know it's not
fear-driven uh like I think a lot of
people are because he's not like that
yeah well it's not like Joe Ro or Joey
Diaz the feature for him in an arena in
Atlantic City you know and and all this
chaos and Ari fear and Duncan and all
these wild people you me all the you
know who wants to really follow that
it's someone that wants to get better
and help people that he thinks are the
best and you know so yeah not having the
fear driven yeah I mean he followed
Chappelle in that arena in Columbus two
weeks ago like butter like it was
nothing and it was you know he doesn't
have that part in if he doesn't have
that fear thing really exactly fear is
not a factor for him it really isn't
that crazy yeah no it really isn't and
if it was you'd never fight I don't
think you could see it he's a diabolical
human being like I mean you know
obviously he has a just like anybody
nowadays there's a ton of haters out
there that can pick apart this like oh
horse paced but like anything you try to
get them on it's easily provable that
right you're just wrong like people that
are you know oh he's not a good stand-up
well you're crazy because all of your
favorite stand-ups think he's an
unbelievable stand-up comedian every
single one of your favorite comedians
thinks he's a great comedian knows he's
a great comedian he's been doing it
three decades just because you know him
from a podcaster from my vermec dinner
from CNN it doesn't change what reality
is there's a lot of opinions out there
yeah but someone like him and it's so
rare there's not even there's not even a
second place like he's like
you know as far as helping people and
you know staying humble he's an
incredible inspiration in that way and I
think
yeah it's easy for that to slip away and
once someone thinks that they have it
all figured out I think that's when it
starts to slip and he doesn't do that
he's constantly writing he is he's new
at his hour now though when I saw two
months ago man it was it's I mean you
don't want to say it's the best stuff
I've seen him do but that's okay to say
it's the I yeah I think he's done a lot
of really really great stuff it's the
best stuff that I've seen him do and you
do want to say that about people because
you do want them to continue to you know
yeah it's like 20 years in to be doing
the best stuff it's where you're
supposed to be really exactly but man if
[ __ ] that [ __ ] really really floored
me I think there's something about you
know mainstream media going after him
that made him want to be even better
I'll show you idiots I saw the same
thing yesterday I was hanging out with
my buddy John rich country music star
hey you told me about him I gotta get
him on here oh he's amazing and he's you
know he leans hard right harder right
than some of those faces on Bell's palsy
but
everything he says makes yeah like
Liberty Bell's Palsy yeah
he's a killer you know what I mean and
he's just he's got the best intentions
and he's a great guy and they come after
him all the time because he's like I
think everybody should have a gun he's
on Fox News sometimes you know what I
mean like he is uh he does stand for
um what he thinks is right and what a
lot of people it turns out think is
right thinks is right and they've come
after him a lot lately and so he played
us a couple songs because he's he's like
you want you guys want to hear a song
this was number one on the billboard
charts for 12 days and nobody talked
about it none of the media nobody
because he didn't use one of the big
record labels and he because he
criticizes the
um
he criticizes the uh
the uh censorship of Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube in the lyrics so he
decided he's not going to promote it on
any of those things so he literally just
promoted it through truth social and
Rumble
these like yeah my mother loves those
right and literally number one on the
billboard charts for 12 days we bring
that up people didn't know what to do
he's above lizzo he's above Taylor Swift
he's above all of these things and he's
talking about these things that he's
always felt and we made this correlation
him and I were like whoa because we both
you know we've been living in this world
the last couple years where people are
trying to chop you down and it makes you
more of who you are he's always sort of
been don't don't take my money you know
I'll you know less taxes he's always
been that but now the lyrics are clear
he's literally saying what he wants just
like how I've doubled down in my
stand-up and now I'm only
exclusively talking about stuff that I
shouldn't be talking about I have all
those premises to myself because so many
people are you know obviously you want
to be on Netflix you want to be on this
you want to be on HBO sure who doesn't
want to be but the reality is that none
of my stuff could be there it would
literally just cause a riot you know
people would just quit or whatever right
but but the people love it it's that
live show effect of like whoa we're
doing it oh my goodness he just said
that OJ's wife had a comment like oh my
god what the hell whereas as you evolve
too because you had a special on Netflix
a few years back but as you evolve it's
like yeah if the platforms won't allow
certain stuff or they don't just see
okay this is just humor that's for some
people not for some whatever
but if they only want to kind of
navigate a certain area or only willing
to go to certain which like you know
banisters which is their right but it
does create
not only for putting things out on
YouTube but really for going to see Live
Comedy it's like if you want to see kind
of what I really want to say come see
Live Comedy yeah and I find myself
wanting to talk more about things that I
want to talk about
um I just even realized last time I'm
still telling a lot of jet like jokes
and stories and stuff and I love that
but I would love to probably have a
little bit more
I just noticed I'm kind of evolving yeah
I was just kind of noticing I was like
okay I love this stuff this is good it's
entertaining but also I want to start
thinking how do I get more of some of my
actual
thoughts right passions yeah things that
like really move me you know yeah so I'm
glad that those feelings are even
arising in me yeah what do we see right
here country music star Sun so-called
woke record labels and released a song
directly to Donald Trump's social media
app true social uh catech poulting it's
a number one in the world on the Apple
iTunes song chart and the billboard
which even this isn't covering yep Rich
saw his song outperform Those hit makers
such as Billy eilish Kate Bush and lizzo
hmm
here I am with no record label no
publisher no marketing deal and when
he's telling you this and you're in his
[ __ ] living room sitting around
Johnny Cash guitars and pictures with
him and all all beautiful home I went
there for a party once yeah and I mean
he's the real deal he's you know a lot
of people just again just like Rogan you
might just know him as a guy you hate
because he's on Fox News sometimes or oh
he used truth social I don't like that
but in reality again this is a guy
completely respected by all of his peers
in his industry so
you know for him when he's telling you
like dude I did it and I didn't even
do it the way that everyone has done it
to this point he literally did with this
song What Rogan did with his podcast
he showed an entire industry of you know
they invite the whole world to come live
in our land and leave our countrymen
dying in Afghanistan they say let go of
Jesus and let government save you can
have back your freedoms if you do what
we say yeah he's putting it out there
isn't he yep he's saying what he feels
progress It's strong I just single I
gotta check that out yeah it's cool
interesting man I'm not sure what that
version's like but I just heard just him
with an acoustic guitar yesterday in his
living room and it was unbelievable and
there it is right there number one go
back to that please brother
yeah number one song right there and it
stayed there for 12 days that's the
other part that you know even this
article obviously came out when it
happened so like it doesn't tell you
that staying number one for 12 days is
its own insane accomplishment that those
things are always rotating and jumping
around
and there it is a dollar 29. and boom
and he gives you know percentages of his
earnings
to uh he has his own scholarship where
he gives money for kids to go to college
who if they had a parent die in the
military he pays for their college he's
given over a million dollars to put kids
through college so you find out that
some of these bad guys are the good guys
and that the good guys you look at
Catholic priests and stuff like do good
do this that's why like virtue signaling
and a lot of and I keep ragging on La
but it's like you know a lot of these
people that want to work in the industry
say all these things they're always this
is wrong and that's wrong and why you
know what about science and all these
different things but
it almost seems like the good guys
sometimes are the bad guys right the
politicians oh yeah Greece I've always
hated politicians right and but I think
we start to see that that whole mold all
that it's not it's not really working I
think you know for a long time people
believed in it there's something good
here yeah but I think after especially
after
um
the pandemic
um after people being scared in a lot of
cities you know and violence I think
people are starting to just wonder
what's going on here I think it's yeah
it's deeper than just
like in our daily lie it's like this
bigger thing like does the society that
we constructed and that we've been
building and riding
what's going to happen to it like which
way is it going to go you know
um and perspective right like the other
night after a kill Tony taping I was
telling my producer guy that uh I go
it's so crazy I just had five different
people come up to me and literally say
the same thing of I can't believe
that you get to be mean to people for
two hours every week on a show for a
living and I go and I had another five
totally different people on my way up to
the Green Room say I can't believe that
you have created a format to help people
and you're the only person giving these
random people a shot to be seen and it's
funny how
they're all at the same show and these
people are seeing two different shows
kind of you know what I mean and I think
it's that way sort of for everything
nowadays sometimes something can be
right there and we choose what we like
about it or what we don't like about it
right well it's bummer too sometimes
it's like I wish I could press a button
more and get a different perspectives
like it's like sometimes I'm like man
I'm so
I'm not inhibited but I am inhibited by
my own perspective not that it's right
or wrong sometimes it's both but that
it's like man I wonder what life is if
you're what has life seemed like if
you're this person if you're a woman if
you're a man if you're black or
um
what is it Japanese you know or you know
I'll just like wonder what it all seems
like you know
um because then it's like yeah My Views
off are they on is it okay if they're
just right for me in my own space you
know I think that's the part that starts
to feel kind of scary sometimes it's
like well these are my views for my
perception
um is it okay to share them if I can't
get everybody if I can't
you know how is it okay to share them if
even if I'm without taking into context
what other people's views are like it's
just it's hard right it's hard sometimes
yeah you know
um because you try to you want to be
open-minded you want but you also want
to respect what you intrinsically feel
you know and I think that's another
place another area where the pandemic
hit hard like people like me and you
that went out and were like we need to
be around stuff that's open we need to
go out once in a while listen to music
or just be around people or just be
somewhere that's open
you know that's a character trait you
know what I mean and I think that a lot
of people that stayed in and stayed
locked down and things like this
um created almost a little bit of uh
bitterness towards those that might
speak a little bit more freely because
we know people better because we're
socializing more and out more and we
might have a Japanese friend or a black
woman or this or a transgender or this
or that or anything so we sort of can
speak more freely because we feel like
we know these people and this and that
and meanwhile some you know person who's
at home on the internet who never goes
out can be like you know you shouldn't
even be talking about right this is what
we have to because it also caters to
that person's life but also guys like
you and me I think we never really liked
the rules right you've never liked the
rules hell no no never you've never
liked the rules and so anytime there's
rules or some type of control that comes
in I re I really don't like that right
it it hits in a place of me I don't want
to be
you know I think it goes back to just my
childhood I didn't like where we were I
didn't like the whole position that I
got put into in my life when I was young
blah blah blah so it's like I'll reject
anything that tries to [ __ ] make me
be some type of way right it's a
blessing and a curse I think sometimes
yeah um
but
what uh so your dad passed away when you
were a kid I heard you mentioned that
earlier no he was uh he's alive
um what type of job did he have he ran
an Italian restaurant and did some uh
some bookying basically Youngstown sort
of like a little Italian mafia Hub so
everybody there when I was a kid was
involved in organized crime and some
effect or another including my mom who
was running numbers for the whole city
it was a big illegal gambling operation
that she used just to put me through the
private school there and make sure that
I had a new pair of Nikes once a year
you know what I mean I was like poor
people put the cards out to people and
they would Circle the games and that
sort of thing yeah yep well it was
mostly like betting mostly like you call
and it's like all right I'll put 20 on
the Packers and and but the thing that
my mom was doing was also like writing
down numbers so you could play like the
Pick 3 lottery or the Pick Four lottery
and it was like straight or boxed which
means you're playing it straight up or
the three numbers come out anyway it was
it's crazy that I used to like just see
her on the phone like writing down
numbers and like doing it all the time
and collecting money from people that
would come over and she would just grab
a roll of cash from them and
she would put me through private school
with that just enough to survive you
know people think that families from
that are involved with organized crime
are always rich and have a mansion like
in The Sopranos and a big SUV but it's
like it wasn't like that in Youngstown
it's like the lower class mob
um
so my dad and my mom
uh were married to other people
when they had me and they already had
kids so they was having Affair totally
oh wow forever for 11 years they were
having an affair super Affair I was a
super bastard before it was cool like an
extreme bastard wow because my dad
didn't want my you know my mom didn't
want me to have my dad's last name
because obviously he had a family around
the corner and the whole thing's a mess
but did her husband know that it wasn't
his kid correct they hadn't been having
sex it was just one of those like back
then you know 1984 divorce was like
frowned upon and this and that but once
she came when she was like pregnant
they're like all right it's time for you
to find another place to live and wow so
he was out and I was in and the rest is
history it's crazy wild times but it's a
lot of unacceptance it feels like he
probably felt like you didn't fairly fit
in with any exactly luckily my four
older brothers and sisters on my mom's
side were super open like no you're a
hinge Cliff you're one of us you're you
know we got you and that's another thing
that changed my life is like I was
raised with this Council of much older
brothers and sisters 12 years 14 18 and
20 years older than me wow yeah so I
have a sister that's 58 right now
yeah it's crazy that's cool and my
youngest brother is 50. yeah 12 years
older than me
so like I used to go down they my mom
used to ship me to Columbus Ohio for a
month every uh every summer when I was
out of school and I would just get to
hang out with my brothers and sisters
who were going to the Ohio State
University so there I was a little
nine-year-old hanging out with a bunch
of 20 something year olds and me trying
to make them laugh when they were stoned
I didn't even know they were high they
would just all go to the bedroom for
like 20 minutes and then come out like
giggling and I would try to make them
laugh and I would do goofy stuff yeah
you gotta fit in magic tricks and all
this lame stuff to just try to entertain
them and it was fun they thought it was
great and they thought I was funny so
like little things like that it's where
it all kind of started
but yeah the dad not ex the dad always
trying to impress the dad thing was a
big deal I mean it is with anybody again
to reference The Sopranos like and to
reference everything you know it all
goes back to like crazy Psychology from
our very we are a product of our
childhood so crazy isn't it totally and
I mean it's so interesting when you
really let go and realize like yeah
we're not that we're not that original
we are like a victim of like the story
is written early on we're just playing
out the script that our psychology wrote
right I never thought about it like that
me neither I've never said that before I
like that it's like the psychology that
[ __ ] was written right in the first
couple years exactly and now we we are
just following the yep because I found
out at a very early age that my dad my
mom used to tell me that my dad was a
truck driver I think it was or something
like that I can't exactly remember that
part but it was some job where he was
traveling a lot
and uh one day on the school bus we went
to pick up my buddy Jeff Lewis over on
Coronado and
um I noticed a car that looked like my
dad's across the street in the driveway
so it's only like three four five blocks
from where I was raised and I look over
and I memorize the license plate maybe I
wrote it down I don't know and then the
next time he came to visit which was
usually like once every couple weeks or
so or maybe once a month for you know
half an hour
um next time he came over I matched up
the license plate to this you know to
this Bronco that I saw every day when we
were picking up Jeff Lewis
and
and I didn't even bring it up to him
because I never wanted uh I never wanted
to like
start any trouble I always wanted him to
think I was cool but I said to Mom after
he left that day I go so
I noticed that his car is always in a
driveway across the street from
uh Jeff Lewis's house on Coronado and
she like looked like she had seen a
ghost because he's like she's like oh my
God this 10 year old just figured out
that
his dad lives right around the corner so
then once I realized at such an early
age that my dad was just a few blocks
away every day the whole time and she
sat me down and told me everything so
all of a sudden I realized like my mom's
kind of a liar and my dad is raising a
whole different family right so all of a
sudden there's this fire inside where
it's like I'm gonna get him to like me
one day I'm gonna get him to know that
I'm the cool kid right cut to two months
ago Pittsburgh or no maybe a few months
ago but Pittsburgh Pennsylvania the
middle of an arena PPG Paints Arena
where the Penguins play where you know a
bunch of crazy stuff happens only 50
minutes away from Youngstown Ohio and
him and his girlfriend came out and saw
me and you know he's like 75 now or
whatever and like he's just he just
couldn't believe it he I mean there's no
I don't yeah it's just crazy especially
being from Youngstown you just never
think you're gonna see anybody in the
middle of an arena that you know
performing to a sold out 360 degree
crowd floor filled all the way to the
upper deck and you know doing good
because we're working this whole time
you know what I mean so it's like a lot
of laughs and he comes back to the we I
we gave him full access to the green
room because there was like a a big
fight that night it was um Anthony
Joshua versus uh what's his name the
best
best big box Fury yeah
and so in youngstown's a boxing town so
now he's backstage with me Rogan and
we're watching boxing on a big screen TV
with never-ending you know you know what
these fancy green rooms are like there's
gourmet pizza and anything you could
possibly want coffee right whatever
you're in the mood for cooler filled
with all your favorite soda pops
and like you know I realized I like did
it kind of you know what I mean that's
like hell yeah it was like the it's a
real
sort of undeniable
victory that I'm like oh wow I didn't
even realize like this is cool because
it's what
it's what you want yeah you want to
impress these people that made you with
their body parts I know it's so strange
tricky because he came out of his weiner
because he squirted inside of my
mother's vagina I need to I need to
impress him and show him one day that is
even good he didn't even have the
biggest win probably basic wiener oh
totally nowhere nowhere near our friend
here yeah nowhere near yeah it's funny
man I don't know sometimes it's like
yeah I think I'd wanted to be seen so
much by my mother that it's like I
started I had to get everybody to see me
and it was like hopefully one day my
mother will see me you know and it's
like I don't even know if I'd have gone
on that whole journey if I just had this
sort of uh attention or affection you
know right it's pretty fascinating man
um I think that that's a real through
line in our Industries like I I would be
interested to know who the funniest
person is that had both parents there
and caring about them and eating dinner
at a table with like a nice place mat
every day and like you know what I mean
a glass of ice perhaps the little things
you know what I mean that like seems so
normal that for some reason nobody on
The Comedy Store lineup you know what I
mean like what are the odds you know
what I mean it's interesting man
meanwhile if you sat at a table with
Engineers they'd be like what do you
mean your parents weren't there I don't
get it what do you mean a place man of
course you had a place man yeah on a TV
tray I would make frozen pierogies you
know what I mean and disgust yeah oh
yeah yeah an engineering like my mother
was 35 degrees to my left my father was
at 70 degrees and
my father was four blocks away [ __ ]
so close
ask for that's almost
that's all it's kind of heartbreaking
it's wild but I wouldn't have changed a
goddamn thing yeah I live my dreams and
I'm happier than ever and you know it's
just wild it's it's insane yeah and that
shows with goofballs like you sold out
shows on the road get to go to different
cities and hit up people like John and
you and you know whoever's in that City
these relationships that I built from
doing dirty stupid jokes all over it's
like so yeah it really oh it's really
lucky it's the it's really the gift of
not getting those things and then
getting them in little increments from
other people you know from people that
care enough to support you uh to believe
in you to like you it's like you slowly
get little bitty drops of all of that
that you needed long ago you get it from
people it's pretty amazing yeah it's
funny because I always thought for so
long man how do I change this past it's
just so impossible right so all I can
really do is just move forward uh with
what I have and be grateful for it yeah
um Tony hitchcliffe man hell yeah dude
so much bro thank you this was so much
fun yeah because uh you know we've known
each other for a long time but I have
never really gotten to really just sit
and kind of learn about you and I
appreciate it man heck yeah you know I'm
proud of you thank you yeah likewise an
honor to be on your show you're
hilarious I'm excited to do more shows
here tonight yeah it's gonna be fun man
kill Tony if you guys haven't seen this
you really need to go and see it live
people love it online it is a huge
following on YouTube it's out every
Tuesday every Monday at eight every
Monday at eight Central Standard Time
um yeah but it's always there on YouTube
we've had our some of our biggest shows
lately we're like hitting a stride it's
crazy to think that like this thing that
I work on forever is better than ever
but well it's so pure that's the thing
about it yeah it's like [ __ ] no wonder
this isn't on television no one because
that they can't do that there's too much
there's too many cooks in the kitchen
there's too many knifes and spoons in
the bowl this is just a [ __ ] dirty
real porridge dude but you guys pull it
off really well and there's enough like
other production value that's there even
when you're there in person it's like
there's moving cameras and there's
things going on and it just man it is uh
it blew my mind when I went back when I
went back and did it thank you um it's a
mat it really is it's as unique as
something could be man well we can't
wait to have you back on I'd love to
come back man Tony Hinchcliffe thanks
bro
[Music]
reach that ground I'll share this piece
of mine I found I can feel it in my
bones
[Music]